hello
friends
hello
hello
i started every stream the exact same
way i'd say hello
whole bunch of times
well hello
good morning
good evening good afternoon
we are alive indeed
what's up gb how are you today
welcome
uh
welcome
[Music]
it's rick
oh wait
hello
everybody what did i do here
why is this like this i don't like it
now there we go i fixed that
okay
i thought you aren't gonna stream today
why wouldn't i stream today
huh
i'm right here bro
drinking some water
7 p.m here in sweden
nice
happy leaf eriksen day
oh god we're in i forgot we were in
blight town dude oh no
what is this
that's all the way down to like quay lag
right all the way down to what am i
doing up here then
scared
america
yeah that's okay
time zone differences confuse me
what time is it for you guys right now
it is noon on the dot for me right now
i'm trying to get down to quay lag
i swear there was an easier way to get
the quai lag but let's do it
let's do it
pizza and chinese
um
dude go for the
chinese mate
go for the chinese
i don't know where i'm going
are those dogs
[Music]
hey nice
i just tried the sneak
this is not elden ring
are you kidding
i thought i heard one behind me okay
1pm
i'm from mexico
1am on a tuesday
it is 1am for you esther
the heck are you from
okay
still getting shot at this does not look
stable
there was one platform what the
what the heck is that
i don't like that thing
okay nobody attacked me here
hong kong
oh wow
small world
everything's really easy when you have
just the best
weapon in the game you know
apparently a very low drop rate got it
first try
many bosses were killed i don't even
know
okay i think i need to go down there
why does it look gross though
no reason
i don't know what that is that looks
like a succubus
we're getting some big boy souls here i
like it oh no
trash
[Music]
i've killed four main bosses really
i'm glad you guys are keeping track
because i'm i'm just out here playing
the game you know
wait this is where it came from right
wait right
this is somewhere different
oh
oh oh oh
this is the very beginning i wouldn't
call it the very beginning
dung pie
it's the
it's where the dung eater originated
is is blighttown obviously
okay that was a weird
ow
okay that's toxic
wait don't i have that moss stuff
wouldn't that help me out here
oh well that's convenient as well okay
oh god
uh
you you
[Music]
that did not help me in the slightest
actually
okay this is bad
what the f
okay holy ragdoll dawg
i'm good how are you
okay i feel like we're making some type
of progress here
i gotta have another one
um
okay
the other moss
okay
i don't have the other type
oh
nerd
is it blooming is that the one we want
oh that looks cool
he hasn't repaired his weapon why do i
need to repair my weapon is it
is it breaking
it doesn't look like it's breaking
oh no
i died
how am i alive
oh
calculated totally fine
i'm i'm dead aren't i
i remember there is a bonfire over here
somewhere
right
run
why can't i run
i'm dead
it's over friends
well
it's on the other side isn't it
when it says weapon at risk it does a
lot less damage yours hasn't yet but
give it time
[Music]
where would it tell me that it's
breaking though
like isn't it usually just like a red
line under the uh
the item on the left like bottom left
i don't even see that
yep i died isn't there an easier way to
go through here
like i i don't remember doing all this
stuff
yeah it's death number one for the day
chat off on purpose no
the chat is on
what are you on about
[Applause]
oh you mean for the on the screen
no i don't think it's i think it didn't
there we go
that's what you meant sorry
let's not get toxic poison this time
i think we'll be okay
there's a shortcut to here but it
doesn't matter
i'll be okay right guys
god
three
708 damage right there
is this thing going to hurt me
i answered my own question
get annihilated kid
oh my god
i do have the master key
i just annihilated that guy
that went right up the bunk hole
i thought i was at a range
french
i thought he'd die
wrench
i don't know what he's doing
okay let's try that again
get ready to stare at a big ugly spider
okay
okay it looks like the only way i can go
is like down here so
what happens if i don't go through here
what if i go down more can i even do
that
oh god
we're taking some risks today
am i supposed to jump to that
oh no
i was like you kidding me bro
imagine doing this with like five frames
that all the people who played the
original had to do
okay i end up in the same place anyway
so that was completely
worthless
go to new londo use master key and
there's a shortcut
oh yeah
i don't know how to get there from here
though that's the problem
i think we're fine
we're already doing way better right
we're already doing amazing
let's not fall into the abyss this time
that's a good idea
okay okay
let's just slowly progress downward
hey listen some kind sometimes you guys
do lie to me i did the same thing as i
did before
i was looking at chat i blame you
okay you guys said it was on the other
side right
is it not right here
keep heading south do you see a compass
sir
is there a compass
we would never lie to you in a million
million years okay
should i try and get my uh my souls
okay
let me try that again
kindle it i probably should actually huh
let's do that
so i'm gonna need two because i'm hollow
as well
so
use item
two
running around the girls
okay offer humanity
long
union restored kindle
i love my nokia kindle
who's the hardest boss in ds1
probably on scene smoke right i would
imagine
that's the hardest one what's over here
there's a little hole right here
is that a chest
okay there's a ladder i was scared i
couldn't get out
nah this one's fake dog
wait it's not
a dragon scale what does that do
artorias is pretty hard
yeah i know the dlc is like pretty
[ __ ] good in this game right i think
i only played the dlc once like a long
time ago
okay
do we go fight quit lag
i can't upgrade right now
we are not anywhere near a blacksmith
oh
god
it's mildred
can this bug leave me alone please
maybe help me
yeah i think i killed her
excellent
[Applause]
what do you got for me
humanity butcher knife
i got 10 000 souls for that
or around that
neat
we already got the dragon scale we
literally just picked it up like just
now
the quail eggs in here
way lags domain oh i should use this
this is the right one right
okay
wait why'd i have 11
the flash are these things
who do i get to fight with
solaire
wait didn't i just murder this person
okay
you can help me
or aries the entire game that has
ambient music yeah i was pointing that
out yesterday where there there isn't
any ambient music in this game
whereas elden ring it's everywhere
i wonder why they changed that
all right let's go man-eater mildred
imagine i summon her again and she tries
to kill me again
[Music]
ew
yeah all status effects are just like
you stink
uh
booba
so mature
okay let's see how we do here
i don't remember what you do
decent start
don't walk into the lava
that's exactly what she did
hey
man eater are you serious
i didn't mean to do that i didn't mean
to do that
pretty obvi pretty obvious
guys why is this so easy
[Music]
[Applause]
guys
thanks for the help mildred
really appreciate it you running into
the lava
did we beat the game just by having this
weapon that i have it i haven't even
upgraded it yet isn't that insane i
haven't even [ __ ] upgraded this yet
wow
do you hear breathing
you hear that listen
who's breathing
that's kind of creepy
i do kind of look like patches don't i
let's upgrade
i think i have the soul of quailag as
well
first try
her follower
uh oh what'd i do
did i [ __ ] up
illusionary wall
oh yeah i remember that
[Music]
it's eg
i think i've beaten dark souls 1 one
time
and it was a long time ago
oh [ __ ] that opened up the gate
cool
but i've beaten dark souls 3 like uh
many many many many times
okay i'm gonna use my souls
[Music]
uh where's this illusion wall you guys
are talking about
this is calling out to me
okay it's not that one
this is the remaster just because it
does uh 60 frames
dark souls 3 was my first so that i
think that's why it's my favorite
why do you keep asking me where i'm from
whenever i don't answer you the fourth
time you should probably like take it as
a sign that i'm not gonna answer your
forehead
right here isn't it
i'm smart
i'm so smart
hello
do i have to kill you oh oh dear
what have we here
are you a new servant
yes i am obviously
but you have no eggs
no matter
go along and have audiences go along and
have
wait who am i meeting
i don't know a ton of lore in dark souls
i ain't gonna cap with you
got it this must be an awful existence
there okay
sad who is this
she's hot too
reinforce estes flask
i don't have that can i talk to you
oh you don't talk
chat who is this
is this her sister or her daughter or
something
it's her sister
do they know i just murdered
their sister her sister
is she aware i just murdered
her oh it is sister clay lag
all right we're not gonna talk about
that with her okay
she does
[Music]
okay what stats do we need for this
weapon because i i'm obviously just
gonna keep using it uh
[ __ ] i unequipped it
such a silly forehead
toggle stats
why is it not telling me
there we go
this is where i wanted to get to
toggle display 32 strength 18 decks
almost there
okay
kill her for a soul i'm not gonna kill
her
she seems chill should i enter her
covenant or no
wait i'm already with solaire i don't
want to join her covenant i just
murdered her sister they're gonna kill
me
split
sorry
sorry
i won't explain why i'm sorry
she doesn't really care you killed her
sister in the lord because quailag was
evil
why does this seem like an elevator
if you enter her covenant you can save
solaire okay i'll go join the covenant
okay
you guys seem to be big on it
got even this music sounds like
it's full of despair
okay uh inner covenant
does she like that
[Music]
okay
chaos fireball
that didn't seem worth it at all
[Music]
okay i'll come back when i have more
humanities
i need 30
okay
we'll come back we'll come back should i
go this way
thank you jack
i've never seen dark souls
it's a pretty good game man i played it
one time a long time ago so i'm kind of
relearning it with chat right now it's
kind of fun
very inviting inviting very inviting
area okay
[Music]
excellent
do these guys attack me
what the hell is that thing over there
there's a boss room
should i go this way
you don't need to complete this area
right now okay i won't
how do i get back
oh
i gotta run all the way back huh
it's one of the best pyromancies in the
game
not a pyromancer though i guess i could
become one
eventually
the boss is free
i'll come back i'll come back
isn't that boss just uh
what's its name
it's something like sexual right
homeward bone wouldn't that just take me
to the last uh
actually can it take me back to
like if i can it take me back to the
fire link
yeah ceaseless discharge
you can you can't tell me that's not
sexual
go through the shortcut to get back up
oh okay yeah the one you were telling me
about
it's kind of like near this bonfire
right
yeah it just takes you back to the last
one which i guess would be helpful but
as long as i'm here already it doesn't
matter
it's the er tree the [ __ ] look at that
or it's the great tree
i don't know man i feel like elden ring
is connected to these games in some way
i really do
okay i'll just take the hit here
you can go to that tree
it's basically elgin
i'm kind of excited to play dark souls 2
as well because i've never beaten dark
souls 2
i played it though
but i never beat it
yep the remaster has all the dlc and
stuff
comes with it
oh i see
i think there's a strong connection i i
think there is a lot of people are like
no it's a totally different thing
it just feels like it and i'm like okay
i see i see that too i see you
i don't know
i still
think elden ring is like a dream state
or something
like none of what we do in that game is
actually real
i still think that i just don't have
enough evidence to support it
is this harder than elven ring
um so far this game has been really easy
and i've died to mostly fall damage
did as hell boy
dark souls 1 dark souls 2 the bad
they have limit spells for a sorcerer
i don't think that makes the game bad
yo alden ring you can have a ton of
spells though
is this the shortcut yeah it has to be
gravity has been gravity's been my
greatest enemy for sure like
beyond
anything else
damn i kind of shred dude
i love it
wait he's just screaming
oh god i'm dead
go through the iron door
yes daddy
yeah yeah i think the next place that we
need to go
is sen's palace right or sends fortress
but i definitely need to
go upgrade my weapon
even though we're doing
amazing damage
mind you
uh we could be doing more
so yeah we're gonna do that
welcome home
this is rick uh he's just bald right now
he's not patches
you are so different when you stream
than on video
i guarantee that's the case for every
creator you've ever met or ever watched
because i am a [ __ ] goofball dude
i really am
but i like the lauren elden ring
kinda
ah
that music feels so nice
that's why they don't have any ambient
music because when you hear music you
know something's going on
no we haven't seen patches yet
are you still in here okay good
i don't have this fire keeper's soul
so he's not always bald no
not always
okay so how can i get okay i know how to
dude i'm telling you
the level design in this game is awesome
because there's so many different ways
to get places oh no
why do i feel like i'm about to get
ganged up on oh hello
my guests have finally arrived i see
that we'll be departing with them
shortly so
i'm afraid i will be saying goodbye soon
it was a pleasure
we barely talked dog
wow great good to hear
what have we here you look awfully
raggedy time's a grim the least you can
do is look sharp
don't you dare meet my lady like that
you might scare her off for
good you
motherfu
okay sheesh
you are undead as well
then we've no time to fraternize i have
my mission and you no doubt have yours
we must not let this cause overcome us
okay
did i not explain the urgency of our
tasks who are you so uncouth as to lack
such judgment by the looks of you
i should think not
i don't like these people and i'm
leaving they insult me
i don't like him i don't want to kill
him but i don't like him
i guess that guy didn't give a [ __ ] that
i met his lady like that
elden rings lore is so hard to grasp but
yeah worth playing through again and
again so many lore details that are
miscible
i i i agree i
i don't know man
you know now that i'm kind of changing
up the content it might be okay to say
this but
correct like tell me what you guys think
but
i think eldon rings lore
is
purposely uninterpretable
which makes it sort of frustrating
to try and understand
okay
go level this bad boy up
who is melano there's like that's this
is kind of what i mean is there's like
five different things melna could be
but we're never know we can never
be a hundred percent sure
on almost anything
you seem to be doing all right
need anything forged
i killed that black knight and i got
this uh on the first try
reinforce
okay nice one whoops
[Music]
okay i need two more twinkling tits
remember that guys
neither of us want to see you go hollow
[Music]
the games are supposed to be left up to
interpretation which i think is
beautiful and annoying yeah i agree yes
is this your first soul game no
laura i feel uh like the games
are like that but we might get more info
with dlc no we always find out more in
the dlc for sure
we always find out more in all the dlc's
for all these games
like for bloodborne we learned a lot in
the dlc for dark souls 3 dlc really
explained to [ __ ] time
uh
sakiro was really easy to understand oh
we need to go send fortress over here
yeah i know elden ring was a first for a
lot of people
[Music]
which i think elden ring is a is a great
way to get into these games and sort of
understand
them
because i think if people came back and
played dark souls for the first time
before any other game i think they would
just find it annoying
don't you think
it's a snake
i don't like snakes
now
i'm scared of snakes
what
i didn't
oh i did hit the thing
all right there's one death since one
death incense fortress great
at least we're two shot in these guys
you know
i didn't realize i hit the trap i
thought i was far enough ahead of it
elden rings my number one game out of
the soul series
uh it was for me when it first came out
but the more i've played it the more
it's gone down my list
because the the open world side of eldon
ring
wait what if i do this and they get hit
by it
they can actually
okay they stagger
excellent what was i saying
i don't remember
could we play golf i learned how to
don't know the terms
uh
get about 200 feet first swing at 13.
i don't play any sports ball so to speak
i can tell
uh golf wise that you're new but
do you mean 200 yards
for 200 feet because usually you're
either talking meters or yards
in golf
it's a snake
oh god the ragdoll
yes yards yeah 200 yards at 13 is pretty
good absolutely
and if you've never played before
heck yeah
what has it gone down
um
like on my list
um i i would say
maybe third
behind um dark souls 3 in bloodborne
why did my character do that okay there
we go
is this a mimic
all good
holy [ __ ]
not a mimic
ooh two large tits guys nice
oh why is elden ring gone down on your
list
okay
hard hard to explain
and i think it's just because i played
it so much that i feel this way because
my first play through i it was my number
it owned
it was my number one for sure just
because i i
eldin ring is so good it's so incredibly
good
um
over time
it really wears on you how big the game
is
does that make sense
like they talk about replayability in
elden ring and it being like you know it
very true that it's a thing
but the game is so big that the
the early game i don't want to do more
than
more than once or twice
because it's just it's so hard to get
a new character back where you want it
does that make sense
like i would need to like think through
my thoughts here
there it is
do i need to go up or down here
i think i can go either way
yeah i i think the open world is
beautiful but when you've seen that
beautiful open world
a bunch of times it you it loses that
wow that just killed me okay
i didn't run that's my fault
and i'm i'm talking about something else
but yeah it's so big
that you just
sometimes you don't want to deal with it
you know what i'm saying
yeah i think the ball hit me three times
that's kind of weird
somehow hit me three times
yeah
that's okay i didn't think he could fly
that far holy [ __ ]
okay
okay
destiny's a good word for that situation
i was meant to die there
yeah i have died to mostly gravity
and things that aren't like enemies in
the game it's crazy
like we killed quail egg with no problem
like at all
and it's because of this weapon honestly
[Applause]
i get vastly different feeling playing
replaying bloodborne than i do elden
ring yeah i've replayed um oh here's a
good way to put it i i don't want uh
i don't want to make a new character in
elden ring but i did for all the other
games
i don't even care that much about new
game plus like maybe once or twice
but that was it in elden ring
i'm i'm only doing new game i don't i
don't even want to make a new character
stay up oh god
all right that was luck
that was luck right there dude
holy [ __ ]
okay we're gonna be fine
i just want to say that's not what i
wanted to do at all
it really shaky hands
who's your favorite boss in this game
oh i don't know
i think sif is cool
this thing coming
i guess not
there it is
oh
okay
ornstein smoke is obviously like the
most popular one yet
favorite dark souls 3 boss
is there a bonfire up here
i don't know where this one goes
dark souls 3.
i know yorum is uh i like yorm
i don't really like the fight i guess
because it's
a gimmick
oh i see
i think abyss watchers are my favorite
i would say abyss watchers
okay
i'm just kind of walking around right
now i don't know where i'm going
artorias is really cool
is that an elevator
why do i get the feeling i don't want to
take that because there's blood on it
is there a door down there i can't see
yeah sips way better than ratagan's wolf
that's pain
okay
where's the chain it's a mimic
i killed it before i even got up
i'm a god
lightning spear that is the exact same
sphere
that nile uses
in [ __ ] elden ring
almost the exact same design
it's down here
i don't want to go down there that just
scares me
why does everyone say owen seeing smoke
is the hardest
um i think it's just a likable
one
it's a likable gank fight
like people like ornstein
smoke it's a good fight
i'm lost where do i go now
it's pushing it that way
i guess i didn't need to go up these
stairs right here
the rocks fill up the pit
how would that help you though
hey yo what up guy
okay
[Applause]
okay
okay
there's an item back there the rolling
balls can fill up the pit
a rare item
you guys like rare items huh
oh okay
the gold serpent ring
ow daddy that hurt
i see an item right here
gotta get those shinies her chat gets
mad
that snake was a girl
so
now she's dead
nameless king
is the nameless king in dark souls 2
okay i don't think this is a mimic or
checking okay
the ring of steel protection is that
good
let's see
can i get more ring slots i feel like
two's not that much uh
who's defense in physical attacks
that sounds good
how hard was sister frida for you
extremely difficult
however i think melania is harder
what's the best osc nds one we're gonna
have to listen to him
why is this like this now
i didn't press the lever dog
i can't move
who hit the lever
okay that's just not okay
ten yeah
do you only have two in dark souls one
okay does that mean i need to go down
oh it discerns itself
as you guys said it filled up the pit
down here
following following
oh i see
so now we can go in here
okay
how about this gold serpent ring
okay that's the rare item
moose item discovery okay i'm not really
big on that since i already have the
best weapon in the game you know what
i'm saying
like we're good
should i go this way
i feel like that way is death i don't
want to go that way
i feel like that'll just lead to nothing
oh
item discovery go
yeah i'm just rocking with such an op
weapon right
frida is the only boss i rage quit on in
all the games
yes sir wait what does this say
what
it's not open from this side
well that's lame i think you should open
from that side
you stupid
[ __ ]
i'm lost
where do i go familia
that's pushing them that way
what's inside you have right now
i don't know
is that here
is that on the screen
i remember i need to get in a cage right
all those [ __ ] boys down there
your pc broke first time you played
melania
or fought
the path is in the room with the machine
okay i'll go back up there
yes daddy
i'll do whatever you want
it's got to still be shooting this way
right
i guess not okay
do i need to go this way
i haven't gone this way yet actually
yeah that's just a drop off into
nothingness
into despair
melania infected the scarlet rod of your
pc
indeed
well that didn't work
oh is this a different path right here
it is
i'm a little dumb aren't i
you can say yes i know it's true
it's okay it doesn't bother me
oh snake
okay
another snack
looking good
looking spicy as per use
oh what is this bs
okay i got a plan
go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go
this place is a hell hole
any games that you would recommend
not yet
i'm excited for pray uh not pray stray
i will go up i'm doing
things okay
y'all need to calm down calm your
titties
and help me find some titty shards
oh
kill the titan i demons i didn't see any
there's a bonfire close by yeah there's
one right there right
are they trying to kill me oh [ __ ]
all right i'm glad i jumped down here
because i was definitely dead
okay we're one away from having the full
ability of our weapon
okay
hello
mommy
i love you
wait do i want to go back here
maybe
hey
it's eg
checkpoint unlocked
we're not even gonna need it we're gonna
be just fine
my partner wants me to get in a monster
hunter
since there was recent dlc or something
i've never played monster hunter here
it's good though
no backstabs
these guys swing so slow it's so easy
all
right okay
katarina armor is good
if someone suggested the armor i'm
wearing right now so i'm just gonna wear
it for now
we find something better we'll rock it
am i still trying to be murdered
cats make this game 100 out of 10.
yup
can i get one of these
open it's locked
i can't get in that one
okay
[Music]
yeah i'm excited for stray
i think i'll play that for for youtube
or cut back to start
i'm not gonna need it
i mean i ain't gonna cap we basically
beat the game because we have this item
for this weapon
it's a gg
i regret coming up here
keep tweaking in the corner please thank
you
my heart
oh
he's tired
that's so sad
my boy got [ __ ] tired dude
okay
i remember you
i poke at his cankles right
and then he'll fall
let's do this thing
yeah the ui in this is very i would say
the ui is
bad
it's just straight up not good
but then again it's from like
2011. i'm dead aren't i
i'm alive somehow that's incredible
i'm hitting the cankles boys
i'm gonna kill him
i killed him upright i didn't even have
to knock him off
all right
it's lit
first try no prob
where does this take me
i pretty much have beat the game because
i have this weapon it's just over
i got anor londo here
the anal rodeo
wow so pretty
[Music]
you the cage key
looks like i didn't need the cage key
it's the lore for those flying creatures
their cringe
you like that lore should i make that
into a video be a three second video
can i jump up here
nope
oh my god they're so big
are you chill
okay
i'll take not get an attack
never mind
scratch that
oh
this gave me a lot of insight uh my
answers i don't know
i can't answer it because i don't know
we're gonna need rust remover in this
area my god
it's so orange
i feel like something's here
okay never mind i was wrong ignore me
copper or bronze i mean
yeah that's the same lead up as it is in
uh dark souls 3. that's really cool
is uh is dark souls 2 a completely
different area than dark souls 1 and 3.
holy [ __ ] is that a person
or hold on i'm gonna level up in front
of your face
okay
[Music]
okay
it's a completely different area okay
yeah i never beat it so i don't remember
she's nice
it's not lined up with the other games
then why
don't that
weird okay
man we're looking good
are we kind of
like killing it
i feel like we're doing really good
well
you are a rare visitor welcome to the
lost city of anor londo
thanks
if you seek lord gwyn's old key i do
exit here
and head straight yonder
if you are the chosen one
a revelation shall visit
what follows thereafter depends upon you
hmm
she's a fire keeper
what is it
what am i
well i am the keeper of the bonfire
if not for me
what beacon would there be in this lost
city
a gatekeeper
and a guide
that is my calling
okay
have fun with that
uh i played dark souls 1 a long time ago
only one time
so
starting to remember everything she said
to go straight right
let's go this way
yeah it's hard to remember everything
but i remember most stuff
okay okay
yo what up bro
i killed two of you
okay
okay
this game would look so pretty if it had
a remake you know what's crazy
this is a remake
it's a remaster
get on
i was much better at shooters i played a
lot of call of duty in my day
it was a call of duty normie
well that's a problem okay let's go back
there's a secret path over here right
not secret
but it's like over here i have to run
along that thing
that's right
i feel like so many people would get
stuck here just not realizing that you
have to walk on this platform
broken window
oh god not these guys
at least they die in one hit
come here you cuck
they did
probably time for the hardest
thing in the game is getting across this
area
we can do it though right guys it's
gonna be fine this is gonna be fine
idiot
[Applause]
what a dummy
what a dummy
[Music]
you know
i deserved that
i called him a dummy
i did call him that
i deserve it
oh my god look at rick
he is just not
looking his best right now
oh
i mean
what is the percentage of deaths i have
i've had to fall damage just just
falling to my death
it's gotta be like 90 of my debts
at least
is the next boss ornstein smoke
i guess ornstein is like uh ornstein
smoke is
like half the game like you're you're
halfway done once you reach that right i
would say
kinda sorta
yeah we'll figure it out
okay let's not be a freaking dummy
this time
okay
it really made these pathways like just
big enough to hold the character huh
ear bad
i need to shut up
like just shut up
like how does this happen to me
why does he still have a hitbox after
he's dead
dead
i just can't i just can't insult them
it's it's just instantaneous karma
instantaneous karma
never seen it work so fast
anyway
why does my guy run bow legged you see
that
that's so weird i think it's the boots
okay this is the one
right guys
[Music]
come on
let me get some water
i think i had it right next to me okay
like what is happening right now
maybe avoid high elevation
i uh i don't think it's a choice
how many days do you think i can uh get
this
get this run done
i feel like we can do this like we can
beat this game pretty quick
it took us like a month to beat eldon
ring or do a 100 completionist run i
just want to do all the bosses
west lines are kind of hard to follow
they don't like really happen that much
i'm gonna be really careful
it's radon using gravity magic
you're dead
yeah we'll do dlc
you're dead
depends on your skill
yeah if i just keep falling to my death
we're never gonna make any progress huh
okay jake you're a better gamer than
this man
you're better than what you're showing
leave it
pillage the body let the ragdoll fall
you are now open and clear to walk
i am going to walk now
straight i'm going to take a left and
then a right
not get hit by the throwing knives let
this guy walk forward
blast his [ __ ] open i'm gonna wait
for the body
take a couple of hits on the nose that's
okay we're gonna drink it up
and let that guy just be a stupid idiot
okay perfect
now i know i just insulted him but i'm
being very careful as to not fall
everyone take a gander at the big chest
ahead
big chest ahead
pogba walker smile
and we're gonna fall good stuff guys
we did it
sprint you scared boy no metal i won't
i died there three times
just just falling so i was being very
careful
oh good morning
guys the proper phrase is uber
booba
everyone likes bubba
what am i hearing right now what thus
your cringe
that hut
you did
oh i got his helmet that's kind of cool
right
metal we're kind of killing it
no
cap you really are
okay let's keep going
there's got to be some bad boys here
right
sounds like a cat
i know you go through that door in dark
souls 3.
don't forget the bonfire where's the
bonfire here
let me lock on
thanks
okay
okay
okay
okay
is there really one down the stairs of
the elevator you cereal
are you guys frosting my flakes right
now
are you guys frosting my flights
under the turny thingy okay i'll go
check it out
tomb of the darkmoon bonfire
that sounds scary
wait isn't this how i get to the dlc
over here
oh
this guy's just hiding in a corner
should we go to the painted world
whoa
sin where's that guy going
it's a weird path
okay i'll go down one more
okay do i hit this thing
or that thing
this or that
do you have the doll you need the doll
no i don't have a doll
a mini ronnie
that okay thank you
i just hit this though wouldn't it take
me back where i just was
the black iron armor not yet
the round one on the left
okay i just hit this
go
positions
wow i didn't know that
didn't remember that
okay
wow you guys are so cool
with your bonfires
look at that
this is a cool ass bonfire
i'm kindling this one
this one's just cool looking
yeah hit two of those
oh wait i already had to
i know i didn't reverse halloween
[Music]
and kindle that [ __ ]
we gonna kindle that [ __ ]
okay
and now we're golden
what is this thing
ring of the sun's firstborn
miracles
imagine okay now what do i do
send it down not up so i had to go to
the other side to do that
gwendolyn is behind there but you need a
ring or to shoot whenever you're in the
titties
gotcha
gotcha
understood mommy
all
right what is my deal
with falling
you know what it is
it's reading chat and playing the game
at the same time
hi sub zero
like have you ever seen a guy fall more
than me
it's fall damage all the time
yeah do we have to kill the bubba
i am the soldier of gravity
hear me roar
maybe you should stop falling
shane
maybe you should get a better name
that doesn't mean that doesn't make me
think of an insurance salesman
okay
shane
okay shane
okay
i'm scared i'm scared
[Applause]
my ass
they have brains
why are they attacking me
didn't they take me here
okay
who's shooting at me
stop it
right now
where do i go
oh
i can go to this one
i killed patches immediately in
elementary my first playthrough i did
the exact same thing
okay that initial dodge was kind of nuts
are you kidding me
man
dang it
all right
go again
at least i didn't die to fall damage
this time
patches is a freak
we don't like patches here
patches is a stupid forehead
uh sure index
this way
i think
one of i mean i know we've talked about
this a few times one of the biggest
things i've noticed from eldon ring to
playing
i mean at least this one
is is is that lack of ambient music
it is so
quiet
everywhere boss rooms and in areas of
interest you know
it is so quiet
i'm gonna be oppressed
i'm gonna be the dom
put down these submissive [ __ ]
look at that
look how well that worked
i'm the dumb
you're dead never mind
that seemed unfair
how did you not die
okay
yes yes you can jump
technically you can jump
okay we're going
run run run run
okay i'm
trying to think of where to go now
this seems really scuffed and
okay let's just keep walking keep it
moving
don't stop can't stop one stop
let's just go over here
[Music]
okay
look at me go
they call me a gamer
it's such a basic ass door
oh hello it's solaire let's go
what up boy
it's our boy
okay
get that up a bit more
okay
what up man oh there you are you've been
quiet these days i haven't seen you
anytime you see my brilliantly shining
signature do not hesitate to call upon
me
i won't quite an impression i would
relish a chance to assist you
okay
thanks man
you really are fond of chatting with me
aren't you yeah i didn't know better i
think you had feelings for me
pretend you didn't hear that
wow
what do you mean he won't die
you really are if i don't
okay
uh let me kindle this
guys it doesn't matter
used to
raise the sun
praise the sun
become a human
kindle that [ __ ]
yeah he's experimenting that's fine
all of it's fine
whatever you want
i open the store
hello mommy
it is mommy
42 damage by the way 42.
there we go
are you a mimic
nope
excellent
a sunlight metal can i give that to him
no i'm not in his covenant anymore
okay let's see we got oh i remember a
skip here
isn't there a skip here
where is it there it is
let me kill this guy first
okay
you can jump right here right
yep
what's in here
never mind
let's continue
uh can i open that door actually
let's see
the guy looks like a kevin ow all right
i regret what i said okay
you guys think we can be ornstein smoke
first try
i'm gonna go ahead and say no
who designed staircases like that from
software
yeah i don't see solaire anywhere so
let's continue
oh god
it's actually this
[Music]
this music's not inviting
[Music]
such an anime entrance
what the
he got stuck
okay i did godskin duo this is gonna be
easy
never mind
he can shoot lasers
kinda
i am
it tracks so slow
what the [ __ ]
no no
oh no no
hello
this room is so small
[Music]
i wish they could hit each other
why wouldn't i kill ornstein's first
that was my fault
[Music]
thousand percent my bad
[Music]
dang
i got ganked bro
solaire can you help me
please
please please
you really are fond of check if i can't
oh my god
kill smoke first get ornstein's armor
okay
i'll kill ornstein first
or wait kill smoke
first
hopefully that's what you said i don't
remember anymore
there is this there you are
oops i forgot how to jump
okay
let's go down here
pretty quick to get back to the boss
room that's fine okay kill smoke first
got it
is that really hard to do
since this he's pretty aggressive
and it won't let me lock on
i didn't have stomata
i can't move
it's harder
i don't like that
i'm just gonna do whatever comes i'm not
too big on whatever
so you get knocked down really for a
long [ __ ] time in this game oh god
come here
dude
focus up
okay
[Music]
dude
is he laughing at me
okay nice
take that
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
i i didn't hit either one of them there
that's fringe
okay calm down fatty
he's stuck on his body
dude the heck
we'll take it
oh [ __ ]
i didn't do what you guys said but
that's fine
[Music]
oh boy
electric titties
hey when do i go for him i'm scared of
him now
okay
there's a little little
[Music]
opening kinda sorta
[Music]
that scared me but cool
okay
my bad my bad
[Music]
okay
let's wait for the openings excellent
this is going well this is going well
i'm throwing
let's go ahead and throw real quick
[Music]
damn that's a big overhead and his
frickin hammer pushed me out of the way
another big hit another big hit
let him do the butt slam
nice
do like one or two more hits
why did he just hold that one for longer
that time what the heck was the
difference
i can't see
and okay
two tries
let's go
whoa whoa whoa
pretty sure i was here for days my first
time playing the game
gg baby
no leo ring for you it is what it is
that's
fine that's fine
nice see
[Music]
on fire let me
[Music]
is this where the bubba is
is this the location of the bubba
let's get that to 20 uh
maybe a little bit more endurance
that'd be lit
time for bupa
my god oh chosen undead
i am guinevere
daughter of lord quinn and queen of
sunlight since the day father has fallen
in obscurus
i have awaited thee i bequeath the lord
vessel to thee
you may now warp between bonfires let's
go
i'm not allowed to see this oh i'm sorry
just an amazing chest
thank you queen
enter covenant or
talk since the day father is formed in
obscurus
i have awaited thee
once living now undead
and a fitting heir to father gwyn thou
art
o chosen undead and beseech thee
succeed lord queen and inherited the
fire of our world
a grave and arduous i can't even hear
her that good she's so quiet
indeed
we had felt the warmth of fire its
radiance and the life that sustain us
without fire
all shall be a frigid and frightful dark
okay um chat what do you want me to do
do you want me to kill her
what is your wish chat
it's just so beautiful
poker with your spear
mommy milkers big that is not an answer
shoot boobah
don't kill
try thrusting
i'm going to enter her covenant dude
or should i not
chat is always horny
i'm gonna join her covenant
the ring of the sun princess
covenant
serveth established thine guardian hell
yeah
hell yeah
she isn't real
now
she's not real
the music in here is so amazing
wait
[Music]
voice
voice
i ain't no simp
[Music]
rick isn't a simple
[Music]
and thy transgression shall not go
unpunished
damn right it won't thou shalt perish in
the twilight of anor londo
you just lost a covenant that's fine
what'd i do wrong
just kidding
work
okay this is cool i like that i like
that
so who's mad at me
who's mad
she won't remember on new game plus
[Music]
true
over here real quick
does it change the ending i don't know
we'll see
we're just going to get the ending that
we get you know
there's like nothing over here
so she wasn't real huh
the hell is this door okay there we go
he created the illusion
so he knew i liked boobs
who doesn't like boobs
anyway so i need to go all the way back
down now right
is what you guys were saying who the
heck are these fools
hello
are you friendly
i answered my own question
are these simps
looks like it
we're going to do dark souls 2 next and
then we'll do bloodborne
i need to figure out how to get my uh
i need to get a ps5 that would be nice
so we could play demon souls too
real gamers don't love boobs that's
right they love ass
ass or titties
like a little both
oh my god there's another one
well you guys didn't want the copper
color anymore so i did that
hey yo what up why can't i lock on here
it's our friend uh
it's the fire keeper
oh god i am so not alive anymore
but how
this man
is a threat
why do i feel like fire keeper's soul
why do i feel like the bad guy
ass feet
two of you have said feet thighs save
lives facts that's true
flask up that's what we're gonna do baby
once we get some one of these
got a great insurance selling voice i
like it
we used to have foot insurance in my
twitch chat
y'all were there for that
probably not
you guys want to hear a really sad story
that well maybe
maybe won't be as sad after i tell it
and now that you know where we're at
i'm gonna tell you guys a sad story by
this bonfire okay
a long time ago
in a galaxy
far far away just kidding
uh
when i first started making content
back in 2018
i had
a day off from work
i worked in the golf industry i was an
assistant pro
and
i worked a lot
so having a day off was a blessing it
was a big deal to have a day off right
especially in the summer
one day i said i'm gonna stream
now i've been streaming on twitch for a
couple of months i got like 300
followers
and i was like i'm going to stream all
day
that's what i'm going to do
i stream for 14 hours
and nobody even said hi
not a single person
it got to a point where i said to myself
i'm not gonna stop until somebody says
hi and then i got so tired 14 hours in
that i just quit and went to bed
and i went to bed sad
14 hours
nobody
even said hi
thank you for saying hi
appreciate you
but
look where we are now
okay i should upgrade my flask but we'll
do that later what the heck is this
it's candles
hi hi hi hi
i appreciate it thank you
is this gwyndolin
yeah it's gotta be
what'd you call me
forehead
first thou offendeth the godmother
and now thou see fit to trample upon the
tomb of the great lord
i say uh
i am the dark side
the voice acting here isn't very good
let thy atonement for thy deities
commence it
oh i like the music though
[Music]
okay
this music's awesome
[Music]
okay
guys what's what the [ __ ]
[Music]
do i gotta dodge through those okay
um why did that not block it
i guess it goes through it huh
where the [ __ ] am i right now
light bonfire
fire keeper is absent
i gotta run this damn far
oh my god
it goes through solid objects and you
can strafe as arrows
okay i didn't even see the arrows
this is a lot of running people
wait can i not pull it up here
balls
your fault you killed her i mean yeah i
threw a fire bomb
of course it's my fault
you build your own pc
no
or my gaming pc i did
streaming pc i just got
rebuilt
you guys are still f being alive
okay
oh you can't
jump
warp to bonfire well the bonfire wasn't
lit
what the [ __ ] just happened
that guy spun me around
jesus
wow
well i want to kill gwyndolin
should we come back to gwendolyn let's
come back to gwendolyn wait that's the
only one here i have to go this way
[ __ ]
oh my god
did you forget to lid
don't know what you're seeing
go back to bonfire and travel
can somebody tell them even though i
just said it
we just talked about this
we got flown here there was no other
bonfire
go back to the bonfire and travel
bonfire's out
i gotta go to this one
does that mean that there's a fire
keeper at every single bonfire
okay
apparently she's not real she's an
illusion
i don't like being swindled so i
murdered her
i didn't murder anybody she's not even
real
i mean think about it
you just beat a really hard boss
a really hard gank boss
and then you open a door with a woman
with giant
giant chest ahead
come on it's too good to be true come on
people
you're better than that
you know that don't exist
you knew it
that one's so dumb
okay i'm just gonna jump down
okay we're making good progress we're
looking good looking spicy with it
wait why wouldn't
why didn't i um
respawn
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
why didn't i respawn
oh okay wait
why didn't i respawn at the bonfire
right outside the boss room
like why'd i even go this far
yeah is it a glitch
the boss put out the bonfire
i mean i l i went to a bonfire that
wasn't even on
no that's the other one i'm talking
about this one
rest
so
i'm gonna pull these up
i
theoretically i should spawn there every
time right
what
what do you mean it doesn't okay
guys i'm talking why didn't i spawn here
when i died to this boss
the heck
okay
[Music]
it's a glitch
oh
[Music]
good thing your weakest piss
[Music]
[Applause]
why do i speak
okay let's see if we spawn there this
time
that kills me really [ __ ] fast why am
i here
this makes no sense
what is this glitch
in a remastered game
i tried to send it up it wouldn't let me
the contraction contraption didn't move
firekeeper was attacking me just want to
point that out
bro this sucks
didn't change anything in the remaster
i mean they could have changed that
i feel
because you build okay i'm done talking
to you now
and i had i could maybe have killed that
boss in one go of it can you climb up
here no okay good
i'm so dumb
you're not resting at the bonfire you
want to spawn at did you guys
not see me rest at that bonfire both
times
i definitely
definitely did
like 1 000
did
i have never fallen off the anor londo
rafters
because he killed gwendolyn
one right in front of the big lady i
mean we can go check that out instead
be better than doing this
am i getting trolled right now
did i just break the chandelier
why did i do that
hit that ragdoll
okay
[Applause]
okay you think he'd get tired of it
i almost went i almost walked by the way
i want everyone to know that i almost
walked right there
holy [ __ ] okay
let's go to the other one
that weapon art's cool
this reminds me of dark souls 3 anor
londo
squeak
the s3 and
just don't die again thank you
you guys are amazing
and very helpful
i love you
magic block shields no
i have my halberd
let's go this way
rest of the thingy
i'm i'm playing the remastered
i'm not playing prepare to die
nope booba dead
uber dead
oh but dead
i'm sorry
okay
i am sitting
i have rested at the bonfire
yes
here i am
sitting here
okey-dokey then
let's go this way now
you killed the lady that's why you can't
teleport
holy [ __ ]
shut up
like
god
wow
warp two bonfire
the one below me that's what you want me
to do
yeah i already ran all this [ __ ] way
what is the bonfire below me called
prepare to die edition
okay work
what's the lawn below me called
dark moon
dark moon tomb
okay here i am i'm going to rest at it
as well
boop there we go here we are
watch i'm just going to beat the boss
here and then we won't even know if it's
a glitch or not
we have metal we have
keeps making me watch the cutscene which
is not usually how that works
[Music]
howie
[Music]
are those snakes
by gwyndolin
i don't like these these make me nervous
this fight's so bad
all right well let's see if it's a
glitch
they're gummy worms
that's a wicked bad glitch
that's such an awful glitch
where i have to run across the entire
[ __ ] map to get there
a thousand percent a glitch now it's
confirmed
i'm not missing this elevator
you can avoid the small spells though
oh so only the big spell
why is this here now
i'm gonna lose my mind
i'm a poop
not warping again
why is it going up
holy crap
i was on the wrong side
why would i not move the elevator i
can't go down there
now i can
wait no i can't
dude hopefully i can one shot the
moonlight butterfly
hopefully this is down
dang it
can you tell i'm frustrated
alexander
got up that's not what's happening here
i've literally warped after killing the
fire keeper
and
big titty [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you guys talking about
wrestling here is i'm just gonna do it
at least the boss fight music's good
are there green candles
[Music]
ah
[Music]
shoot me with arrows thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i hate it here
i don't even know what i just did either
arrows
okay
[Music]
i'd rather you didn't do arrows
one more
[Music]
i i don't know what i did wrong i don't
know
okay let me let me just please please
please please thank you
your hat's stupid
stupid
hat
i like the music though
yeah that boss fight sucks i'll say that
straight up bro that boss fights poop
is this where she actually was
big boobies
mimic
no mimic
the sunlight blade what are those
flowers
rick i don't want to see your stupid
forehead oh there's another one
mimick
are you for real
just nothing in it yeah i know the mimic
chain trick
if the chain's in
then it's a mimic
but that one's
or like away from me
oh
dude that looks clean
is this armor good
okay i look sick af bro
except i'm fat rolling
hmm
looks clean though dude
so throw that on take those off maybe
a little better a little better
i'm not actually huge on the helmet to
be to be totally honest with you
we do that
and then that
a little better
a little better
um
hmm
change those
to this
get me it's not that bad okay we can't
wear it yet it's too heavy
what was the one you guys were having me
wear
black leather i think
i like it
yeah it wasn't fat rolling but it was
pretty mid
you understand ds3 lore to a good amount
yeah i have a lot of hours in the s3
i have like
probably close to 2 000 hours in dark
souls 3 3.
one of the best mediums
okay we need to go back to firelink
because i think we beat ann orlando
hold up
get that to 20
slap up the health a bit
nice level 54 we're gonna warp
fire
but i've only beaten dark souls once
dark souls won one time
we'll talk to our
fire keeper
by hannah have a good day
that's this flask oh
okay now where do we go
did you help onion bro
i didn't see him where was he
how do you look different
did you ring the second bell
that is incredible i did
did i yeah i did
it snows
and its breath is lethal this is no
laughing matter i tell you
yep only beat the game one time and that
was all the way back when you first were
in my twitch stream medal
oh
yeah
yep
i need to turn up the voices in this
it's quite low
let's just make it a 10 banger
ah
hello
was it you who rang the bell of
awakening yeah i am the primordial
serpent
king seeker fran do you guys think
miyazaki was high as [ __ ] when he made
these games chosen undead who has rung
the bell of awakening
i wish to elucidate your fate
and the very reason your kind have
appeared
chosen undead
your fate
is to succeed the great lord gwyn
so that you may link the fire
cast away the dark
and undo the curse of the undead
now yeah we slapped one of these chests
i assume that you are ready
now
be still
well i didn't know i don't have a choice
he's just gonna okay
i feel like there was a better way to do
this but okay
okay
i don't know about that but i'm high as
[ __ ] when i play them
perfect
this
is the firelink chamber
for the successor of lord gwyn wow now
place the lord vessel on the altar
um
do i want to do that
place lord vessel
just bone out
you want me to boner
you guys want me to bone
he does do a great job on the world
buddy building yeah
okay i i will bone out
if you don't want to meet kath don't
place it i don't
okay i won't
what do you guys want me to do instead
[Music]
if you place it you miss a secret npc
okay
oh kata is another
snake boy
no i don't have a doll i don't think
slap up four kings
it's down below right
we could go to sif
we're going for cath we gotta do sif
yeah let's go do that actually let's go
do that so let's work to
that's the undead parish
i don't know where these are
uh
is it here
it's definitely not every bonfire you
can warp to it's only specific
ones
this is fine
yeah this is exactly where i want to be
let's see if i can upgrade i don't think
i found any other twinkle tit shards
[Music]
well hello again you seem needed
yeah i need two twinkle tits
you need 20k for the seal
is there any other way to get the seal
yeah we can't even do this yet so
do i buy the seal off of him
see
purchase item oh i can buy titanite
shards
[Music]
you don't have to go that way but the
way without the seal is long okay let's
get the seal then
go from hydra lake and kill the cats
you guys are confusing
barry
i'm not gonna kill andre why would i
ever kill andre
uh
[Music]
trying to think of how to get to these
places
one for the fire ending one for the dark
ending if i'm correct okay
i mean i'll do whatever you guys want me
to do
[Music]
yeah andre's a chad
[Music]
giant blacksmith sells twinkle
by the way for 8 000 each
okay that's good to know thank you
[Music]
let's see
now i want to replay this game for the
200th time
i guess we could go
um
let's go to that area that fire area
i guess it doesn't matter where we go
huh
just gotta go go go
hey this weapon we got right here we're
good for the whole game bro
we are good
af
oh is this bed of chaos
i can only play for like
40 more minutes 38 more minutes
i'm gonna try and shoot for three hours
a day
okay
bruce ness you can interact with the
sneaky man oh god i want these guys to
touch me
i think black knight halberd [ __ ]
everybody up
this place is just hell right like it's
just hell
on earth
what the heck where do i go
yeah i want to save solaire
did i go the wrong way
oh i did
whoops
i have to beat ceaseless discharge first
oh
i'll kill seepless
i didn't realize there was a path over
here my bad my bad
how do i how do i save solaire
we saw him in anor londo but he didn't
help us with ornstein's smoke
gotta kill unending relief of load
yes
after you kill ceaseless ceaseless
you're going to want to go back to the
bonfire you warp to and join her
sister's covenant
okay i will
i will do that
i i remember i i joined big titty
covenant and then i killed her
where is this thing
okay
i just run away from this guy right
i remember right
yep that looks like a ceaseless load
hello
okay
that armor looks sick
running
sprinting
do i just keep keep going
definitely following me
the armor's not for you okay
i am a thief he wasn't even messing with
me
oh god
i'm doing good
[Music]
what an odd boss
oh okay
oh it lowers all the lava okay
four hits and he's done cool
that is a fun fact
okay i'll do what metal said
i need to go join the covenant
ceaseless [ __ ] charge
give my sister's clothes back
why do you care so much about your
sister's clothes bro what are you weird
join and give humanity
okay mommy
i can't do pyromancy
i don't want to do it that way either
but i definitely don't have 30 humanity
do i need to give 30 all at once or 30
total
she goes home
[Music]
30 total
okay
i mean
i don't have any
or do i have to have them on me
like blasted
like if i do this
okay
[Music]
you could go to dlc area and farm
humanity there yeah someone said that we
should do dlc now is that what we should
do
you guys cool with that
we could start the dlc because i only
have 30 more minutes
go to uh
absolutely not dlc now
you could
[Music]
what's dupe humanities
[Music]
22 more
okay i'm gonna go i'm gonna go do dlc
um
trying to remember how to get there so
dlc is
over there
it's not called the depths is it
let's go back
oh i don't want to do i don't want to do
a glitch
oh i i think i remember how to do the
dlc
i don't think this is the most efficient
way to get there
but it's what i got going on right now
i'm a little upset that this happened to
me whoa
okay then
i'm the best i'm the best on the map on
the map on the map
artorias is gonna [ __ ] you up fam
listen guys i beat eldon ring we're
gonna be fine
okay
imagine like i bet metal just cringed
elden rings easy
unless you're a bandit
then it's not
they just
just in case i take some fall damage for
whatever reason here we go
that hurt
that is not how you get into the dlc am
i tripping on how to get to the dlc
right now
does i have to go to like havel's place
and go to the serpents and go out in the
water over there
what have i done today you're gonna have
to go back and watch because there's a
lot we've done a lot
[Music]
i gotta kill uh
yeah do i just have to kill the serpent
up here
you kill a golden golem just past the
hydra okay thanks
the hydra hits them too
yeah what's the best way to kill this
thing
pray
ow
we shall kill the very gods
ooh night armor
no
yeah i'll stand over here
[Applause]
wait they don't
what
just happened
what
[Music]
what
now i know there's an edge
do the head stay off
there's a cliff in the water i know that
now
dude gabe we've already beaten ornstein
and smoke today
[Music]
the hydra no like edgy
the heads respawn
oh my butthole hurts
where are you running sir
when are you running
where are you running
okay
where the heck are these
okay mommy
that hurt
this is such an odd fight
oh sick they all stack up in damage
get up
[ __ ]
okay so they all don't go to the same
spot
hey
this thing suffered enough blood loss
yet to just die
or i gotta hit every head
[Applause]
is it trying to knock me off the edge by
leading me over there
okay
what the [ __ ] is that
what do i do about that
attack me
oh i see that edge right there
what the [ __ ]
okay dude
he doesn't always go over there
oh it's hard to see the did he just poop
i mean it's just pooped
oh my god i'm scared of falling again
he's pooping dude
i don't understand
thank you
okay
now i go back here right
the power of poop
i thought it'd be here
you have to reset area i'm gonna
i'mma poop
i'm gonna poop myself
go ahead and take a little
boop
or can i just like quit out of the game
let's test it
[ __ ] it
there it is
you guys sometimes i'm smart
all right can this thing kill me
i'm assuming the answer to that is
always yes
okay
i'm still scared of falling in the water
okay there we go
what the
hey yo what up mama so
it is thou who rescueth me
most gracious i am deeply obliged i am
dusk of oolacile i cometh from an age
long before thine
i cannot stay here for long
so
before i disappear
allow me to ask one thing
my home
ulisel
is the home of ancient sorceries
is to pass this profound knowledge to
thee
with thine approval would this be of
assistance to thee
uh
i'm answering a snapchat
sorry
sorry
uh yes
my heart felt thanks
i am pleased beyond words
then i shout engrave my signature
thou art in need
praise some of me from my signature
seems that my time is done
may the great flames guide thee
okay
now what do i do
chat
do i reload the area again
hey girl hey
professional streamer by the way i was
answering you
okay yeah
let's give it a shot
now duke's archive
need pendant
where's that
no i don't have a pendant
i'm home where i'm i'm boning out of
here i'm bonering out
i don't want to run all that way
the five fingers will take you through a
portal of the elden ring
nice
yeah that sounds lit dude that sounds
lit
where's the archives
for that
you know you know what i think i think
this is a perfect time to stop because i
don't have that much longer to play
i think this is a perfect time to cut it
right here boys and girls
in orlando bonfire inner orlando bonfire
and run
close in orlando okay we'll do that
tomorrow we'll come back tomorrow
same time tomorrow
um
okay it's there and left okay remind me
tomorrow okay because i don't have that
much longer to play it's gonna take me
like forever to run there so we're just
gonna do it tomorrow
thank you all for being here appreciate
every single one of you
i i have a blast stream on youtube bro
it's been great um
i'm definitely gonna do i'm gonna be
streaming a lot lately or
i'm gonna be streaming a lot
so get used to that
um now that elden rings kind of like i'm
out of content with that game to be
totally honest with you guys um
so we're just gonna have fun doing some
other stuff
um
back tomorrow doing the same thing
trying to beat the game
well i don't think we can beat the game
tomorrow but we'll see
um check all the links in the
description i appreciate it if you did
other than that
y'all have a great great rest of your
day have a great night sleep well
eat some good
food
and uh come prepared to carry me again
tomorrow
all right hey appreciate you guys thanks
for being here
i'm gonna go get some food i'm hungry
dude i forgot to eat right beforehand
and i went golfing this morning so a
little tired now so it's perfect time
but i'm gonna go get some food have a
great rest of your day